two months ago y'all watched as colin
sat down and explained in
reasoned level-headed terms that while
north american counter-strike may have
been suffering
setbacks from which it could take years
to recover
it certainly wasn't dead and i think
it's fair to say that
we all agreed with him the problem is
that
since then things have gotten really
bad
[Music]
before we get into the story i've got to
let you guys know we have just recently
partnered with tj sports to become the
official
english broadcaster of the demacia
championship this holiday season
we're going to be live from december
21st to the 27th
bringing you all the league of legends
action that you can handle
so be sure to check it out okay so if
you haven't watched the donate me that
colin did back in october about the
downfall of csgo and na
go and do that because this one is
pretty much a sequel
guys welcome to north american
counter-strike in 2020
where cs go esports are completely
eurocentric where young superstars are
calling it quits
after basically being relocated an ocean
away from their home
needless to say for as much as it's been
memed on over the years
i think it's fair to say that things
have never
looked worse for north american
counter-strike pretty much
everything that colin hinted at came
true successful established rosters such
as
liquid eg and furia have all relocated
to europe
since that's where all the action is and
those who couldn't
or wouldn't were left to flounder the
issue is that the tier
ii and three lineups who were left
behind didn't just struggle
they downright imploded the best and
most
tragic example of this is chaos an
adored up and coming
side who after finishing top four at esl
one cologne n a
and winning the north american divisions
of both iem beijing
and dreamhack masters winter were
stunningly
dropped by their org if there's any
testament to the truly dire straits that
nacs is in
it's chaos these guys won back-to-back
regional titles
and qualified for counter-strike's first
international tournament since
february only to find out that they
would be both without a home
and a banner under which to play their
demise was confusing
concerning and sent the community into
an understandable state of disarray
if the back-to-back regional champs
couldn't stay afloat
who could thankfully i was able to sit
down with chaos's
cat eared commandant anthony vanity
malaspina and
figure out exactly what happened with
chaos what he envisions as being their
next steps
and how grim the future of nacs actually
looks
you see earlier this year north american
counter-strike was actually
slapping pretty hard in spite of all the
issues that kovan created for
tier one orgs who were used to playing
on lan it actually gave
burgeoning lineups like chaos and
furious a chance to stand out
and they took it we were probably the
third or fourth best north american team
but we would go to lands and we would
just lose because we
never played like we played liquid in an
opening match it's like okay well we've
never played these guys in matches when
we put them in practice
so like and it's completely not the same
but now like we played liquid in
probably like 10 maps this year online
we played eg in like six we've played
fury in like 10.
it's like it's not the same it's like
you can scrim them 100 times but like
five
official maps against them is way more
beneficial than 100 streams
unfortunately it just didn't matter how
good they got or how many titles they
secured the region in which they were
flourishing just
wasn't profitable uh i mean we knew back
in like
october i think we were getting released
and honestly i kind of like expected it
like
throughout the year because we were
going to delayed payments and stuff we
never had sponsors
so it was kind of just like uh investor
money and stuff and that's never gonna
last
like super long right so i mean kind of
sucks but it is what it is it wasn't
super unexpected
given like the circumstances around the
year like there was just a bunch of like
foreshadowing
regarding it all and i mean it sucks but
it's not the end of the world
according to chaos's official statement
and vanity reaffirmed this
the investors simply wanted to take the
org in a different direction and to be
clear it didn't have anything to do with
the age-old
optics around counter-strike terrorists
bombs
etc it was just a question of money some
people looked at numbers
saw they were bad and then yeah there
goes our jobs i guess
the beautiful thing is that this gave
way to a genuine
outpour of fandom from everywhere
tremendous support was shown for both
vanity and his teammates
launders even half-memely suggested that
a community-funded org should
sign them all in an effort to save nacs
i don't know
people for some reason didn't like me in
the past because i was toxic in fbl i
guess
and now all of this it's like i don't
know i think people are just it's
definitely nice to see this especially
because like the higher up people that
are doing it it's not just like the
random fans right
there's like casters and like players
i've looked up to like most of my career
that also outspoke about it it's
definitely helpful or definitely like
gives motivation right but it's like
also at the end of the day it
didn't really help so so what are former
chaos's next steps
well according to vanity things are
absurdly up in the air
now to be fair they are getting offers
and counter-strike
they're just not the kind of offers that
he was hoping for uh i mean we have a
few encounters like nothing super
enticing though it's like a bunch of
other it's like just orgs like similar
size to chaos right it's like
i'm not sure i want to go through that
again because it's not
consistent money flow right i feel like
at this point in my career i've like
kind of earned a little bit of stability
i feel like my teammates kind of feel
the same crazily enough vanity and one
of his teammates zeppa
did actually get an offer from gen g
which
would have at least put them on the path
to being on a tier one team
but then earlier this week news broke
that gen g was putting its entire cs go
roster up for sale which was i mean kind
of unlucky i guess but
it is whatever it's esports nothing
makes sense at all i don't even think
the players knew they were getting
dropped until they got dropped
because we were told we would have
contracts and then we see an hltv
article that the rosters released so i
mean it's whatever now vanity did assure
me that they're really hoping to not
have to break up the band
it just isn't clear whether they'll be
able to stay in cs
uh i mean we're looking to stay together
so probably realistically we'll
transition to valor
i don't know at this point there's like
a chance we're staying counter-strike i
don't know how likely but
who knows it's all up in the air it's
esports someone could come out of
nowhere and just offer us
a fair enough contract and be staying
counter-strike but i don't know how
realistic that is at this point i feel
like it would have happened by now
rumors have already started to swell
that their 17 year old prodigy
leif is off to play valorant for cloud9
and the question is whether his
compatriots will follow suit
especially since from what vanity told
me the offers invalorant
are more enticing than ncs as colin
rightly observed back in october one of
the biggest threats to north american
counter-strike
aside of course from kovid is valorent
it's hot it's new it's being superbly
supported by riot games and as vanity
said
it offers a welcome change of pace i
don't know
it's unlucky i guess like counter-strike
probably will still be my favorite game
regardless of which game i end up
playing
and i don't know it'd be nice to have a
new like start there and i think the
bigger
thing with ballroom for me is i'm not
gonna be playing the same game a year
from now
that i am playing today like i will be
in counter-strike i've been playing the
same game since 2015. literally nothing
has changed maybe like the sg and the og
came in and out of meta for like roughly
like six months
a piece so i mean i think that's
definitely one of the bigger things
pushing me towards ballarat because i've
always been like a because i came from
call of duty initially and i liked the
constant change which is i mean most
people don't but i don't know it was
always something i was a big fan of
still it's not actually clear what the
future holds for all of these
let's say non-tier one orgs who are
rushing to get into valor
it's safe to say that riot will at some
point provide valorant with some sort of
franchised infrastructure and
not everyone's going to be able to buy
in i think people are just banking on
the fact like obviously there's nothing
really set in stone yet
they're hoping that riot treats this
remotely like they treat the lcs
which i don't think is super like a i
don't think it's a bad bet to take
right but there's these smaller teams
that i'm not really sure they're like
plans
like maybe they have a bunch of money
sure but assuming if you're not like a
top eight top
10 team i don't see it's realistic that
you're gonna get into the league so it's
like
what are you paying these absurd
salaries for then again maybe these orgs
know something that we don't and will
not be left
wanting in a year or two's time i mean
maybe they have a better plan maybe
they've talked to riot because i've
heard ryan's been pretty open regarding
it to these orgs
so that could definitely be something
that they've had communication with riot
and they're like okay it is realistic
that we're that we could get in
but some of these orgs it just confuses
me but yeah there's definitely a lot of
interest from orcs there's
some bigger orgs that are trying to get
into the game which is cool to see for
sure and we're in talks with some
anyway we will leave discussions about
the future of valorant for
another video probably several
for now it suffices to say that north
american counter-strike is in a
very rough place is it dead
or at the very least dying
the instinct is to say no after all this
is counter-strike we're talking about
that said i really think we shouldn't
understate how
serious this all is as someone who was
born and raised on
the game that later became valve's other
premier esports title
i can tell you this wouldn't be the
first time that they've let one of their
north american scenes
go to [ __ ] i mean you can look at dota
you can see any dota is dead
see valve treating it the same way so i
mean it's not real it's not unrealistic
to say it could be dead within like a
year
i don't want it to die i don't think
people realize how bad it is if nacs
dies
what happens if we leave where do liquid
inferior
liquid and eg go for their next players
that's what i don't think people realize
it's like dude they're just gonna have
to trade
there's not gonna be unless they just
take a random gamble on some kid that's
good in fpl which i mean i don't think
is necessarily bad but it's like
they're not gonna have like this like
relatively high match experience like
i'm not saying we're super experienced
players but we definitely have more
experience than a lot of these players
so i don't know i don't think people
realize like the impact losing all these
like
tier two players in north america is and
potentially will have on the scene in
the long run
could it be that players like tarik
stewie and twists are the last of their
kind what happens to top tier free
agents like automatic or stars to be
like oboe what about those
hyper-talented 14 year olds we haven't
even heard of yet
right now it's hard to say on the one
hand it does
kind of seem like the ones who aren't
lucky enough to get contracts in europe
are gonna end up invalorant on the other
we're seeing little rays of hope
like xc9 getting signed by a brand new
north american org called extra salt but
with cs go's player numbers
booming like never before you never know
maybe valve intervenes
maybe they don't either way it is
distinctly possible that we see a sort
of post-covet renaissance in north
america
but for now let's just hold our breath
cross our fingers
and hope for the best
dude i honestly i don't know why you
play counter-strike against simple i
don't know why you do it
it's a [ __ ] bad idea
oh my god he got close enough to find
the line he's pushing him
oh my goodness like you're gonna have a
really bad time if you
buy and you load into a map that simple
is in and you're on the other team like
why buy guns
like literally what's the point i don't
understand why
anyone in their right mind would play cs
against simple
i don't